as more details surrounding the untimely
death of chadwick boseman's surface the
thing that becomes most clear is just
how kind and inspirational of a man the
world has lost
the years he spent living with knowledge
of his cancer while continuing to make
movies and uplift others
only further amplify the altruistic
nature that everyone came to know him by
meanwhile of course his acting prowess
was undeniable and the role would shine
the brightest for this immortal thespian
was that of king t'challa in the marvel
studios mega hit black panther
after news of bozeman's death rocked the
world fans reeled back any time the
notion of recasting t'challa was floated
for one bozeman largely defined the
character of t'challa for an entire
generation
aside from that pretty much everyone
agreed that it was far too soon for such
talks given that the world is still
mourning the loss of such an important
real-life hero
recently though fans have begun taking
their own route by suggesting an
approach that is less about the demise
of t'challa
and more about securing chadwick
boseman's legacy by placing someone new
on the wakandan throne first off while
it is visibly apparent that no decisions
need to be made about this right now
there will be a certain point in the
future where audiences will expect a
black panther 2.
marvel will have to be extremely careful
about how best to approach the project
without disrespecting chadwick boseman's
memory
the first thing that becomes clear if
the flood of responses on twitter is any
indication
is that the notion of recasting t'challa
with the new actor will not be greeted
well
so how should the story continue
obviously marvel can't and shouldn't do
an entire film with the digitally
recreated bozeman unlike carrie fisher
and star wars
while audiences could perhaps accept a
scene or two of this having a creepy
resurrected cgi t'challa for the film's
duration wouldn't be feasible or
respectful
that means most likely a new character
must be elevated to the throne which
leaves a few options
okoye certainly would be a worthy
candidate mbaku is another one given
that the first film made his interest in
ruling quite clear
however a more clear path forward is
already laid out in the comic books and
fans are already calling for the mcu to
follow suit
after all this structure is in place and
it actually makes a lot of sense
is there any member of a royal blood
who wishes to challenge for the throne
fans have already begun petitions
calling for the black panther mantle to
be passed down to t'challa's younger
sister shuri
played by leticia wright because not
only is sure he been the black panther
in the comics during a popular 2009
storyline but when it comes to
respectfully laying t'challa to rest the
film could use these same comics for
inspiration
the storyline in question features like
varian dictator dr doom
the biggest marvel villain who has not
yet entered the mcu and one whom has
occasionally been rumored as a black
panther 2 villain
the villain joins a sort of
anti-avengers known as the cabal whose
membership includes namor the king of
atlantis a guy who tends to switch sides
a lot
t'challa is offered a place on this team
by namor and he refuses
in response doom proceeds to swoop down
and attack t'challa leaving wakanda's
king in a comatose state
at this point it falls on wakanda's
princess shuri to undergo her own trials
and tribulations as she must finally
claim the role of black panther for
herself
this doesn't go smoothly in fact shuri's
own hubris initially causes the panther
god to reject her but she eventually
goes on to prove herself as a worthy
black panther
this path forward is quite likely
something that the studio is considering
given the fanbase's support
comics featuring the first appearance of
shuri have already seen a spike in value
according to bleeding cool
whatever decisions are made though it's
unlikely that any motions will be made
until some years in the future
which is good and right since everyone
certainly needs more time to remember
bozeman's inspirational words honor his
legacy and re-watch all of his films